congratulations you found the only
murders after show one killer question
or maybe you just hit the button by
accident either way too late now
[Music]
oh hello and welcome to one killer
question the only murders in the
building after show I'm your host
Michael Cyril Creighton this season
Oliver has been so focused on his heart
that he has put himself into cardiac
arrest
in the process he has hurt the
investigation and his friendships has
Oliver been kind of selfish
to help me answer that question I would
like to welcome Ryan Broussard and
Andrea Martin hello hello hello so
Oliver's heart
is it messing with his head
when is it not I don't know really when
is it done
um yeah I think it is I think I think
Oliver's just always being pulled in two
different directions of what is I guess
what is the right thing to do and our
and what he wants it's always a
um I think it's always a battle and it's
very hard to control your life when
you've fallen in love no wonder it's a
pressure on his heart but I don't think
he has any other choice I know that we
all love Oliver I mean he's a wonderful
character we're cutting him a lot of
slack though I'm gonna argue he's been
very selfish throughout the season I'm
going to give some examples of why and
we could just talk about it okay first
off the moment Ben died
Oliver's first thought was that his
opening night was ruined it was a
disaster and he still threw a party well
he had all the Food and Liquor you don't
want to waste it that's true that's true
dips and there was shrimp yeah he had to
tell the rest of the apartment he was
having a party you know it was a lot of
work that went into it yeah you know I'm
not with you on that I think all of you
deserve to have the party okay when his
good friend Charles is going through a
romantic crisis with the delightful Joy
thank you one of my favorite characters
thank you and he has panic attacks about
being on stage Oliver's first choice is
to replace him with Matthew Broderick so
quick is a whip
Matthew Broderick I've had sex dreams
about this moment how did you already
nail that song what can I say I'm a
vessel yeah that's that's a hard line
yeah we'll go yeah we'll go back on that
yeah we'll go hard line on that don't
you think but it is it's Matthew
Broderick
yeah although maybe he's doing him a
favor Charles seems to not want to be in
this play well I think that's what
Charles acts like but in his heart he
wants to be and he wants to prove to
himself that he can still remember lines
and yeah no he doesn't want to believe
that he's of a certain age and how he
can't act anymore I think it's it's
important right yeah all right so this
is a big one because
this entire season for Oliver the
investigation has been secondary that's
what connects the trio that's what
connects Mabel Charles and Oliver it's
the investigation and all he seems to be
worried about is that whoever the
murderer is they're not in his show yeah
when you've gone that long without I
guess being relevant in the field that
you want to be relevant in and then
you're finally given this opportunity
it's like yeah you don't want to blow it
so it's like it forces you almost to be
selfish and I think it's like an
understandable self yep I do too yeah he
has to have tunnel vision in order to
make this work I'm not going to use the
word selfish I'm going to use the word
survival he's in survival mode if this
does not happen and it's a bomb nobody's
going to want him for podcasts for
friendship for anything yes exactly
exactly all right so what do we think
about him erasing the lipstick off the
mirror that's a huge clue yeah yeah he's
a little fragile if we you know let's be
honest he's a little he's a live wire
isn't he yeah you don't want to push him
too much no because God forbid what will
happen to defend Loretta or or to or to
make sure that nothing happens to her
because he's fallen in love with her he
has to betray his friends so it's it's
never it's never a simple solution to
anything that he does it's literally one
of his rules is don't fall in love with
with one of your actors right um so he's
breaking his own rules so you kind of
know how how deep in he is and how in
love he is in the case of Loretta I mean
it feels like he's really taking care of
his heart right because he's letting it
open up to someone else
so while his relationship with his
relationships with his friends are sort
of falling to the Wayside right now he
at least is letting his heart grow in a
different way right he has got some
heavy duty therapy ahead of him oh my
gosh yeah that's season four I guess
so with that we are going to play
one killer game
so Oliver is usually the center of
attention but this episode also features
a minor plot twist Loretta is Dickey's
mother
in the spirit of motherhood let's play a
game called
who's your mommy to get you into
character we've given you a baby doll
and you're gonna give that baby doll
some motherly advice as though it's a
character from the show if I agree with
the advice I will coo Okay I'll say goo
goo and if I don't agree with the advice
I'll cry okay who would you like to give
advice to oh we're going to Oliver
Oliver 100 go for it yeah all right
listen I need you to stop being so
selfish to your friends okay I need you
to be available to them and just you
know be a good friend and be careful
with Loretta okay because she might be
bad news we don't know yet but I just
don't want you to get hurt okay and stop
asking me for money then go to sleep
great oh Andrea who would you like to
give um that was so great Charles you're
gonna give advice to Charles Charles
Charles
you are a sweet sweet boy and I don't
want you to be afraid of opening your
heart you met a beautiful girl and she
loves you so much don't break her heart
ask her back give her a call look in her
eyes and say I love you Joy I know that
my Mommy's gonna love you too
can you do that Charles
Charles
yeah great advice that baby went to the
White Room
uh one more round this time
don't tell me who it is I'm gonna try to
guess okay
seems like you're in a little bit of a
love triangle right now you don't really
know who to choose you know the new hot
you know beautiful handsome you know
green eyed tall man you know seems like
you're having a love relationship with
or the nice guy who you kind of bond
with over murder okay I need you to be
protective of your heart as well don't
make the wrong choice all right it might
end up being the NW okay
very well done Andrea
well you're a beautiful talented woman
and I can see in your future
seven million Awards all for you and I
want to say give somebody else a chance
a lot of people out there
be such a hog
I say Google and that's Loretta and only
Loretta yeah you better believe it
excellent this was so fun now I want to
thank you so much for being here we're
going to need those babies back
and this has been one killer question
until next time call your mom
[Music]
foreign